hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up today
urgent action needed the world's leading
Health journals caught on Wealthy
Nations to step up and help Africa ahead
of this year's cop Summit
the future of fracking labor calls on
the Tories to help end shall gas
extraction with the MPS debating the
matter later today the UK's advertising
Watchdog bands to HSBC adverts for being
misleading about the company's work to
tackle climate change and
the controversial move to acts Sweden's
environment ministry as a 26 year old
becomes the country's youngest ever
cabinet minister
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and interrogate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis now we start Today's Show with
the countdown to cop 27 firmly underway
over 250 of the world's leading Health
journals have come together to urge
world leaders to deliver climate Justice
For Africa now the bottom line richer
countries must increase climate support
for the African nations it comes as
devastating floods continue to impact
large swathes of Nigeria with over 600
people having died this year what
joining me now is Richard Smith chair of
the UK Health Alliance on climate change
which published this very editorials
thank you so much for joining us on the
daily climate show Richard how do you
hope the world reacts to this message
because it's a simple message isn't it
yeah we've got two simple messages so
this is
259 journals which is very unusual it
includes the Lancet the bmj the New
England Journal of Medicine and National
medical journal of India and very
importantly the message is coming from
16 African editors of journals and the
first message is we must do everything
we can to try and stay below an increase
in temperature over pre-industrial
levels of 1.5 degrees the second message
is that we can only have any chance of
doing that if rich countries help poor
countries we need to do this because
they are suffering more and yet we cause
the problem so we have an ethical
obligation a Justice obligation but also
it's self-interest because there's no
way that we can stay below 1.5 degrees
if we leave people in Africa and the
South to suffer uh the damage from
climate change without our help
and Richard it's good timing isn't it I
suppose with cop 27 around the corner
how hopeful are you that climate Justice
can be delivered for Africa by cop
yeah well cop as you know is going to be
in held in Egypt which is why we
coordinated all these African editors
speaking up and I I think people have
there was some progress last year in
Glasgow there wasn't nearly the extent
of progress we would have hoped for
particularly in terms of offering
support to low and middle income
countries so we're hoping that this can
be the cop where we really make a
difference and recognize just how
important this is and I should emphasize
you know Health journals are doing this
because this is the world's biggest
threat to health
health is severely damaged by climate
change it's happening now it's not
happening in the future but there is
also a positive message because if we do
the kinds of things we need to do to
respond to climate change most of those
things are also good for our individual
health so switching to diets that are
largely plant-based rather than animal
based driving less exercising more
insulating our houses all these kinds of
activities so luckily and unsurprisingly
in a way what's good for the planet is
also good for us as individuals I'm
Richard lastly and briefly one of the
highlights of the reports I suppose is
in terms of adaptation they're you know
their big gains have been made in early
Warning Systems
um it's all hands on deck though that
final message isn't it to make a real
change for African nations
yeah yeah and and you're right to
emphasize adaptation because a lot of
the damage has already been done and is
being done right now so it can't be just
a matter of mitigation you know trying
to keep the temperature down it must
also be adaptation and there have been
some developments in Africa in some
developments here but we are in a sense
even further behind with adaptation than
we are with doing everything we can to
stop the temperature rising higher okay
Richard Smith thank you very much for
talking to us today
okay time now for some of the days other
climate news for you and scientists are
warning that climate change could bring
viruses in the Arctic into contact with
new environments increasing the risk of
viral spillover that's according to
newly published research so the research
published in proceedings of the Royal
Society suggests that as global
temperatures rise due to climate change
it becomes more likely that viruses and
bacteria locked up in glaciers and
permafrost could reawaken and infect
local wildlife
now almost 1 billion children are at
extreme high risk of climate change
harms a children's rights group has
warned now kids rights index based on
figures supplied by un agencies also
said more than one-third of the world's
children are currently exposed to heat
Waves kids rights warn that a lack of
water affected 920 million children
worldwide
now the world's second richest man has
announced he's sold his private jet
Bernard Arnold said he he wasn't very
keen on being tracked by climate
activists on Twitter because some
accounts have been created on social
media publishing the amount of pollution
the Jets admit which were owned by the
Louis Vuitton CEO and other billionaires
too
the UK's advertising regulator has
banned two HSBC advertisements for being
misleading about the company's work to
tackle climate change
the posters showed images of waves
crashing on a Shore and tree growth
rings with the slogan climate change
doesn't do borders well the advertising
standards Authority upheld complaints
that the ads failed to include
significant information about hsbc's
contribution to carbon dioxide and
Greenhouse emissions joining me now is
Skies eye shirts are here um actually
this is a bit of a an own goal from HSBC
yeah absolutely although this is
significant because it's the first time
this kind of action has been taken by
the advertising standards Authority
against a bank for essentially
greenwashing like you said it comes down
to these two adverts which first popped
up back in October 2021 just before cop
26 and they received around 45
complaints from the public like you said
they featured either waves crashing on
the shore or tree growth rings with the
slogan reading climate change doesn't do
borders whilst also detailing
information about hsbc's own green
initiatives namely their 880 billion
pound investment into helping their
customers reach Net Zero and also their
plans to help plant two million trees in
the UK but what it all came down to was
the fact that HSBC failed to mention any
of their own contributions to carbon
dioxide and greenhouse gas emissions the
advertising standards Authority said
that the posters omitted material
information which made them misleading
they said that customers wouldn't expect
HSBC to be making these uh claims they
say while simultaneously funding
companies that make significant
contributions to carbon dioxide and
greenhouse gas emissions like I said
it's the first time this kind of
action's been taken against bank and
campaigners hope that it's going to set
a benchmark within the financial sector
when it comes to putting out
advertisements relating to the
environment and climate change
Aisha zahid thank you very much
the labor party is attempting to force a
binding vote on fracking today which
would allow a bill to be put down
Banning Shell Gas extraction so fracking
was halted wasn't it in the UK in 2019
and made opposition from Green groups
and concerns about Earth Tremors but
that decision was reversed in light of
soaring energy costs our climate change
correspondent Hannah Thomas Peter can
tell us more fracking is just one of
those issues that won't go away you'll
remember David Cameron declaring that he
was going all out for Shale gas and then
a few years later and several
earthquakes later by 2019 there was a
national ban on the practice and it
seemed like the industry was over in
this country but now we have
um a new prime minister in the shape of
Liz truss she has lifted the moratorium
on fracking she wants to explore to see
what's down there
um amidst an energy crisis she's argued
that expanding fossil fuel production in
the UK is is the right thing to do
however this has infuriated a number of
conservative MPS particularly in the
north of the country where there are
lots of fracking licenses already
approved whose constituents are very
opposed to having fracking restarted on
their land or near their homes and it's
meant that these 30 to 35 MPS have
become strange Partners or unlikely
partners with labor a party which is
also opposed to fracking perhaps for
broader reasons their interest in the
direction of travel in this country they
want to accelerate investments in
Renewables they see extracting more
fossil fuels as a backward step but
whatever the reasons we've got this
strange partnership developing and it's
all coming to a head because labor is
tabling an opposition motion which would
essentially today in the Commons start
the process of forcing the government to
reinstate the ban on fracking and these
Rebel Tory MPS or potential revelatory
MPS are toying with the idea of voting
with labor now the government let's try
process has is obviously very concerned
about this there's now three line whip
in place
um Liz truss's operation saying uh to
the potential Rebel MPS you can't allow
labor to take control of the agenda like
this this amounts to a confidence vote
in the government labor is saying uh to
these Tory MPS you've got to think about
what's right for the constituents and
for the country and you have to abandon
your party on this issue but for those
Tory MPS they've got a very difficult
set of decisions to make because they
know that if they support their own
government on this issue they they risk
the anger of their own constituents and
therefore their own political survival
the next time the country goes to the
polls
and finally just before we go Sweden has
appointed its youngest ever cabinet
minister 26 year old woman
has been appointed as the country's
climate Minister well the new government
in Sweden has been criticized after
scrapping the ministry of environments
in the 26 year old will work under the
minister for energy business and
industry instead of leading her own
Department
now let's just over two weeks until the
United Nations a climate change
conference in Egypt and you can scan the
QR code on your screen for your full
guide to cop 27.
well that's all for me back to you Sarah
Jane